we look on social media and we're just  affronted with all these shoulds of what  we should be doing like we are of a  thousand different lives versions of  success that we should have and so I  think it's satisfying in and of itself  sometimes that you need to have a  purpose and to get that across but it  can only really be something that you've  set for yourself you know because  otherwise it's just arbitrary standards  of success you know if it's someone  else's if it's an award that you're  getting or you know a job that you're  getting like you don't really have much  control about that so I don't know  that's not worth gambling happiness on  [Music]